We're just a few days removed
from what we assume
was Serena Williams' farewell.
Thoughts on the aftermath?
RENEE MONTGOMERY: You know,
the first thing I noticed
is that the post
that she posted after,
she posted herself in the bed
and said,
"I'm enjoying my weekend,
how 'bout you?"
And so I don't think people
understand that about athletes.
The first thing I saw was like,
she probably finally had like
the best rest of her life
in the sense
of not worrying about--
Before she even retired,
I remember last year
people were asking her,
"When are you retiring?"
So there was that lead up
to when you start
to get a certain age in sports,
people start to retire you.
Like, "Oh, hey,
when're you done?
You know, you're 30 now,
what's up?"
And so I just thought, for her,
I was like,
for her to go out
the way she did
you can tell
that her trajectory,
there's more stuff coming.
But, I don't know,
I just feel like
that's GOAT status,
we saw it.